اعلنت اللجنه التحقيقات الفيدراليه
الروسيه اجراء تحقيقات بشان استخدام
مسيرات في اراضي شبه جزيره القرم وقال
متحدث باسم المكتب الصحفي للجنه انه سيتم
اجراء تقييم قانوني لتصرفات جميع الاشخاص
المعنيين بحسب تعبيره وقد اعلنت سلطات
الجزيره تفعيل انظمه الدفاع الجوي مساء
امس الاثنين في مدينه جان كوي شمال شبهي
الجزيره وكانت معلومات اوليه افادت باصابه
شخص اثر سقوط حطام طائره مسيره على احد
المنازل
وقد عرضت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه شريطه
فيديو لقصف اطقم المدفعيه ذاتيه الحركه من
طراز ميستا بي المركبات المدرعه والمدفعيه
والمواقع المحصنه المموهه للجيش الاوكراني
اشارت الوزاره الى ان الطاقه ما يشمل
العسكريين الذين تم استدعائهم من
الاحتياطي في اطار التعبئه الجزئيه وتظهر
اللقطات المنشوره وابلا من نيران مدافع
152 ملم قبل تدمير معقل فصيله الجيش
الاوكراني ويبلغ مدى مدافع الهوت زر ذاتيه
الدفع مستر ب 30 كيلومترا وهي مزوده
بذخائر شديده الانفجار وذخائر دقيقه
التوجيه